your dating and you're dating multiple  women and women know that other women  want you they get more excited by that  so when it comes to a situation like  that she knows that he could go and get  other guys but then that being said if  you're being faithful to her and not  exercising options to her she's like I'm  the one who's won but I still the thing  is it's competition anxiety in it you  need they need to understand that they  should never think that you can't get  anyone else but them let's let's be  wrong because no woman wants a guy who  no other woman wants it's just not how  it works yeah that's true I mean like  I'm a faithful man I'll just put it out  there right now faithful man but us get  attention every now and then from girls  and it was my wife up but she knows in  it like obviously I'm not going to do  anything because I'm a mad man you know  I'm